STEVE: BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLETENESS DEMOCRATS HAVE
MADE WITH THE ELECTION SYSTEM
WE STILL DON'T KNOW FOR SURE
WHO CONTROLS THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES BUT WE CAN BE
CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC IT WILL
BE THE GOP TO FINALLY GET
ACCOUNTABILITY OVER BIDEN
AFGHANISTAN DISASTER AND FAUCI
AND THE HANDLING OF THE
PANDEMIC IN THE BIDEN FAMILY
CORRUPTION ALL THE BIDEN IS
NOT TOO  WORRIED.
>> WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE
CONSIDERING INVESTIGATING YOUR
FAMILY AND YOUR SON HUNTER'S
BUSINESS DEALINGS?
>> I THINK THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
WANTS TO MOVE ON.
STEVE: MOVE ON?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
THOUGH WORST FORM POLICY
HUMILIATION AND THE PANDEMIC
THAT KILLED MILLIONS AND
CORRUPT BUSINESS DEALS WHILE
YOU ARE VICE PRESIDENT KNOW
THAT WE ARE NOT MOVING ON.
JUSTICE DEMANDS TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
NOW WHO MIGHT HAVE THE POWER
TO BRING THAT ACCOUNTABILITY
AND HOUSE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WHAT IS IT LOOKING LIKE TO
YOU?
I'M SURE YOU'RE ITCHING TO GET
ON WITH THE WORK WE BE IN THAT
POSITION TO START THE
INVESTIGATION WILL REPUBLICANS
TAKE CONTROL?
>> I DO THINK WE WILL IT LOOKS
LIKE TO 20 OR 221 WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT AND TO
BE CHAIRMAN OF THE OVERSIGHT
WITH SUBPOENA POWER TO TAKE
STEPS TO HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE.
>> SEE MAY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE SIZE?
EVEN IF IT IS A MAJORITY OF
ONE?
IS AT THE SAME AMOUNT OR
ACCESS OF 30?
>> YES.
218 IS THE MAGIC NUMBER AND
THEN TO HAVE SUBPOENA POWER
AND THAT IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE HAVE REQUESTED A LOT OF
INFORMATION FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL WE HAVE
BEEN IN THE MINORITY AND
BLOCKING A SET OF RETURN.
WE FINALLY HAVE THE POWER OF
THE SUBPOENA TO GET THE
INFORMATION THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE DESERVE ANSWERS TO.
STEVE: AFGHANISTAN FROM A
ORIGINS OF THE
PANDEMIC, HANDLING OF THE
PANDEMIC IN THE BIDEN FAMILY
CORRUPTION.
DO YOU HAVE SEQUENCING AND
PRIORITIZATION WITH MULTIPLE
INVESTIGATIONS AT THE SAME
TIME?
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT WORKING
OUT?
>> A LOT OF DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES ARE TAKING STEPS WE
WILL NOT DUPLICATE SERVICES.
AND THEN TO PARTNER WITH OTHER
COMMITTEES OF JURISDICTION
WHERE WE CAN WORK TOGETHER.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE EXPECT
RESULTS FROM COMMERCIAL
OVERSIGHT AND EXPECT THEM
QUICKLY.
WE HAVE TO BEGIN WITH
DEPOSITIONS AND TRANSCRIBED
INTERVIEWS.
REFUSED PEOPLE TAKES A WHILE
IF THEY HAVE TO GO TO COURT OR
HOLD PEOPLE IN CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS AND THAT TAKES TIME.
WE ARE FAR ALONG WE HAVE BEEN
PREPARING FOR THE DAY WE ARE
READY TO GET STARTED WE HAVE
MORE INFORMATION AND THIS
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY OF THE
HOUSE OVERSIGHT.
AND THAT IS WHAT THAT HELPS
OUR LIVES AND NOT JUST
PURSUING POLITICAL ARGUMENTS
AND INVESTIGATIONS.
>> WE WILL BE FOCUSED ON THE
THINGS THAT MATTER TO EVERYDAY
AMERICANS.
INFLATION TRYING TO SECURE THE
BORDER THAT'S WHAT REPUBLICANS
IN THE HOUSE WILL TRY TO FIX
BUT AND THEN TO WEED OUT WASTE
FRAUD AND ABUSE AND I CANNOT
THINK OF MORE ABUSE THAN WHAT
WE HAVE SEEN WITH RESPECT TO
DOCTOR FAUCI AND THE QUESTION
WITH HUNTER BIDEN IS HOW DOES
HE AND HAVE THAT INVESTIGATION
INTO THE BIDEN FAMILY
INFLUENCE PEDDLING.
>> THAT IS THE PART OF THE
SWAMP AND THE ASSETS BUT IT
DOES COME BACK BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THEY ARE FOCUSED ON
INSTEAD OF SOLVING PROBL